[Música]
cuando yo estaba chiquitilla creía que
el dinero así nacía mágicamente de la
billetera mi papá o de la cartera mami
allende me ven con esa cara de buena
ciudadana que tengo le pegue una
regañada a mi abuela porque llego a
visitarme un día a la casa y no me llevo
una rico la pulpa y la hice de vuelta la
devolvía la pulpería comprarme algo y ni
siquiera me pregunte si ya tenía dinero
para comprarme algo mismo porque
obviamente el dinero aparece mágicamente
en los adultos
bueno les voy a decir muy honesta es esa
idea o ese concepto de cómo se crea el
dinero no la cambia hasta hace mucho
tiempo ella seguía pensando lo mismo y
seguía teniendo mucho de magia para mí
y si les pregunto a ustedes me imagino
que también vamos a ver levantando la
mano cuartos de todos aquí hemos estado
en una mesa sentados decidiendo cuántos
colones o como se crean los colores
alguien mayoría
yo tampoco
qué pasa si les pregunto esto piénselo
en su mente y respondamos esta pregunta
cómo se crea el dinero piénselo
segundito como respondería usted esa
pregunta cómo se crea el dinero
yo no puedo saber exactamente qué
pensaron todos los que están aquí pero
después de siete años de hacer la misma
pregunta a muchas personas más o menos
pienso que ustedes dijeron algo así como
bueno el dinero lo crea el gobierno o lo
crea el banco central que tiene muchos
economistas y esos economistas hacen sus
cosas de economistas verdad y revuelve
un poquito de oferta y demanda y un
poquito de inflación y le ponen unas
gotitas de pib mezclan todo
como magia
se dan cuenta seguimos pensando lo que
pensaba yo chiquitilla del dinero lo
cierto es que sabemos poco sobre cómo se
crea el dinero pero tenemos por lo menos
una idea los bancos tienen algo que ver
tanto el banco central como los bancos
comerciales y como todos los bancos
centrales del mundo siguen el mismo
modelo del banco central de inglaterra
que es ese que está ahí
vamos a ver qué dicen ellos sobre el
dinero que según el banco central de
inglaterra el dinero es un tipo de deuda
y hay hoy por las siglas en inglés yo te
debo
y dicen que existen tres tipos de dinero
el efectivo que todos conocemos los
depósitos bancarios numeritos en una
cuenta y las reservas del banco central
esta es la definición oficial que acepta
el sistema financiero a nivel
internacional eso quiere decir que tanto
colonias como dólares como euros como
pesos todos en realidad son el mismo
tipo de dinero creado de la misma forma
y este tipo de dinero se le llama dinero
fiat o fiat man o dinero creado a partir
de deuda
yo no voy a profundizar ahorita mucho en
este tema de cómo se crea
y el dinero basado en deuda pero si les
voy a hacer una cosa no me encanta no me
encanta esta definición así como tampoco
me encanta la deuda
yo prefiero una definición que mi esposo
que está por ahí sentado y yo planteamos
en el libro nuevo dinero para la
sostenibilidad y lo escribimos y la
planteamos muy inspirados en el trabajo
del profesor belga bernard lietaer que
ese señor que está ahí en la foto que
lamentablemente falleció hace poquito y
él fue uno de los arquitectos del
sistema euro la definición que
proponemos dice hacer
dinero es un acuerdo
recuerden que un grupo de personas una
comunidad que decide aceptar algo lo que
sea algo me teme estandarizado que les
sirve por lo menos para intercambiar
entre ellos dinero es un acuerdo eso
quiere decir que para crear dinero no
sólo necesitamos deuda lo que
necesitamos es un grupo de personas así
como nosotros que se pongan de acuerdo
en algo que vamos a quedarnos con esa
idea con esta definición y vamos a hacer
un poquito de magia la tirada que me
tocó después del mago de verdad pero
ustedes van a ayudar yo tengo aquí mi
varita mágica digital de súper última
tecnología y tengo mis maravillosos
asistentes y ustedes van ayudar a ser un
poquito de magia cada vez que yo mueva
mi varita mágica así
usted va a ayudar con una palma si vamos
juntas
esta fue sin magia porque es torta vamos
hacer una con magia de verdad él va a
pedir que se concentró en bastante vamos
a teletransportarnos a un barrio de san
josé
vamos a ver
muy bien este barrio es un barrio en el
que la gente trabaja mucho gana poquito
consume los productos que necesitan el
día a día
y bueno hay poquitos colores disponibles
en la economía la verdad es que hay
pocos colores y más cuando hay crisis
como la que sentimos ahorita les está
faltando algo vamos a traerles algo
importante que les falta un lugar donde
puedan comprar lo que necesitan en el
día a día que le salga cerquita barato a
buen precio ahora y ojalá que le den
fiado que que le falta una pulpería que
vamos más que un poquito
muy bien esa es la pulpería de doña
patricia como ya patricia está en su
pulpería todos los días la atiende hasta
los feriados le da fiado a los vecinos
se conoce y hay varias cosas que le
preocupan una cosa que la preocupa es
que se le acaben los productos que más
le compran se le acabó la leche se le
acabó el café el arroz y es una torta
peor si llega el cambio en repartidor ya
ya se le acabó el dinero y no le puede
comprar más
otra cosa preocupante es que se le viene
sobre los productos aquellas cosas que
le compra un poquito y ella sabe que
esto le pasa que le faltan y les sobran
productos etcétera porque ella no sabe
administrar muy bien la pulpería y aquí
va a aprender si no puede dejar la
pulpería sola para irse a llevar un
curso de verdad de administración o de
contabilidad bueno vamos a ver si esto
le pasa solo a doña patricia o le faltó
le pasa también a más personas me ayudan
vamos un 2
no solo a patricia hay miles de
pulperías en américa latina' en costa
rica tienditas que les pasa lo mismo
solo aquí en costa rica hay más de 10000
pulperías que representan el sustento
para miles de personas y que le dan
además un soporte social económico a los
barrios
que aprendimos hasta ahorita aprendimos
que las pulperías les falta dinero a
veces le sobran les faltan productos y
además les falta tiempo para aprender
qué les parece si mezclamos esos tres
elementos lo mezclamos un poquito le
ponemos un poquito de magia y creamos
alguna solución vamos a ver mundos
resulta que creamos un nuevo tipo de
dinero digital exclusivo para las
pulperías que se llama culpes vamos a
ver tu buena la magia esta vez vamos a
ver cómo funciona
doña patricia tiene su celular que
usualmente lo usa sólo para whatsapp
pero ahora tiene una app donde puede
aprender cómo mejorar su pulpería de un
videito completo un cuestionario unas
preguntas cada vez que ya ve un vídeo de
un minuto
se gana 100 pulp es
cada vez que ya completó un cuestionario
se gana 200 puntos y ahora tiene 300
pulp es que ella puede usar cómo va a la
misma tiendita de la aplicación y puede
comprarle 10 cajas de leche a don luís
don luís es otro pool pero que ya ahora
con esos pulp es que doña patricia le
acaba de pagar puede ir y comprar la
leche a otro colega que les que la
estafa de sobrando y si le faltan pulp
es se devuelve a la app de otro videito
se gana unos culpes extra y ahora si
puede comprar que pasa hacia doña
patricia oa don luís necesita más bien
colones bueno entonces venden ese exceso
de productos por la mitad en colones y
la mitad en públicas
y entonces esos culpes empiezan a
circular y a circular conectando a los
pulperos permitiéndoles aprender cosas
nuevas para la pulpería mejorar les
permite tener acceso a productos y
servicios que necesitan y además les
permite hacer todo eso ahorrando sus
colones para otras cosas porque lo están
haciendo intercambiando con pulp es
vamos a ver si esto que acabamos de
crear
cumple con la definición de dinero que
yo les conté al principio
será que es hecho por una comunidad si
la comunidad de pool pero si pulperas
será que usa un ítem estandarizado si
los pulpos es monedita digital y será
que lo usan como de intercambio si
ahorita entre ellos y más adelante
porque no con los proveedores y hasta
nosotros los clientes de las pulperías
podríamos en algún momento usar culpes
porque no y resulta que lo que hicimos
con esta magia fue crear
un nuevo tipo de dinero y este nuevo
tipo de dinero es creado por los mismos
pool pero si pulperas para resolver un
problema que tienen
y se le llama a este tipo de dinero
moneda social que es bien diferente del
dinero fiat que hablamos al principio se
acuerdan que decíamos que primero tenía
que haber deuda para que existiera el
dinero para que lo pudiéramos usar es a
lo que estamos acostumbrados con dinero
social como los pulp es lo que tiene que
pasar es que la gente aprenda por
ejemplo en este caso que mejore su
pulpería para que existan más pulpos
para que lo puedan intercambiar entre
más aprendizaje más culpes disponibles
ellos
imaginen lo que eso podría significar
para las pulperías de américa latina' de
costa rica- podrían trabajar más juntos
podrían estar haciendo un frente común
ante por ejemplo la competencia de
grandes cadenas de supermercados podrían
protegerse ante las crisis que yo sí
creo que hay crisis
si el dinero es un acuerdo
entonces podemos ponernos de acuerdo
para crear diferentes tipos de dinero
diferentes tipos de dinero como los
pulpos y esto ya no me vuelve loca no
fue que me compre una máquina y de hacer
dinero de imprimirlo el mismo banco
central de aquí de costa rica reconoce
la importancia de la idea de las monedas
sociales y ustedes van ahorita al a los
museos del banco central se van a
encontrar esta exhibición donde habla de
una experiencia muy linda de dos
cooperativas aunque en costa rica cope
silencio y copé victoria que ellos
tienen su propia moneda social que se
llama los guys unidades de intercambio
solidario y así como los suyos existen
más de cuatro mil monedas
complementarias y experiencias de este
tipo a nivel mundial mi equipo y yo las
hemos estudiado hemos aprendido mucho
sobre ellas y la estamos juntando con lo
mejor de la tecnología que tenemos
disponible para que entonces todos
nosotros podamos aprender más rápido que
el dinero cómo se puede crear y podamos
diseñar otros tipos de dinero para
resolver nuestros problemas sociales y
ambientales
una de estas tecnologías es una
tecnología llamada block change con
block change podemos crear monedas
sociales como los pulp es como los
huthis podemos hacer que sea de una
forma muy descentralizada muy
transparente pero además de bajo costo y
muy muy segura de manera que entonces
evitamos abusos corrupción robos en el
sistema
el proyecto que yo estoy creando con mis
con mi equipo se llama be spyro y es una
plataforma de código abierto de
corazoncito pico brasileño y que la
hacemos con la pasión y con el sueño de
poder facilitar que más gente pueda
crear monedas sociales en block chain
para resolver sus problemas sociales y
ambientales
y la magia que hicimos hoy que ustedes
me ayudaron a hacer hoy en realidad ya
existe es magia real los pulpos existen
hoy como una experiencia piloto aquí en
costa rica ya al día de hoy alrededor de
80 o 100 pulperos y pulperas están
usando los pulpos empezando experimentar
aquí en san josé gracias a nuestro
trabajo en conjunto confundes
latinoamérica
esto es prontito van a saber más
noticias de eso pero qué tal que si
nosotros creamos los pulpos sino que
creamos las vice monedas y con las visas
y monedas incentivamos a la gente a que
ande más en bici a que use más
transporte verde a que reduzca las
emisiones es verdad que contribuyamos
con esa meta país que les va a dar ahora
el presidente de descarbonizar a costa
rica o porque no creamos los más vida
coins una moneda que permita incentivar
que hagamos ejercicio que me la gano
cada vez que escojo hacer ejercicio no
quedarme viendo netflix pero
yo los invito a que usemos la magia del
dinero
los desafíos son grandísimos a nivel de
costa rica- de américa latina'
las necesidades son grandísimas los
problemas por resolver la tecnología
está lista y la crisis está a la vuelta
de la esquina también necesitamos
alternativas lo único que necesitamos
hoy es aprender un poquito más
identificar ese desafío que queremos
resolver llamar a la comunidad con un
poquito de magia y
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]